hey guys I think so I'm in Shanghai for
a few days visiting family and they told
me about this super cool Starbucks
apparently it is the largest and the
fanciest Starbucks in the world was
actually right there behind me recently
coffee culture has been growing a lot in
China so I'm really excited to go in and
see what it's all about all right let's
go so that's all
[Music]
[Applause]
so we are now inside Starbucks reserve I
got a little too excited but we're gonna
do the discover tasting journey the
Discoverer tasting journey involves four
drinks and one food item of your choice
a write your name down it shows you the
entire map of the place but more
importantly here's our first drink it's
a smoked butterscotch latte we have to
go to the main bar they're gonna make
you the coffee right there at the bar
table you can leave tasting notes if you
want to it's not just about tasting the
coffee it's learning about the coffee
culture and just like what goes into it
so I'm excited let's start with this
super-awesome smoked butterscotch latte
[Music]
this
[Music]
so now we have the receipt we're just
gonna go and get our drink
[Music]
I just got my first drink according to
this pamphlet there is smoke
butterscotch and milk an expresso
in here I feel like this is something we
would get at Starbucks in America let's
give it a shot
it's really creamy actually not super
sweet it's actually really quite
delicate maybe it's a smokiness in here
that kind of adds another layer of
flavor I think this would be a huge hit
if they launched this in America all
right we're gonna go check out the
second drink second location is the
pairing bar I think it comes with
chocolate and there's chocolate over
here let's go so we are on our second
drink this is a section that features
black coffee using the beans that they
roast in-house they have a lot of
different blends ones from Columbia them
Tanzania the one that we're trying today
is called the Pantheon blend specific to
China can't get this blend anywhere else
that means we have to try it but as you
can see it's really just a cup of black
coffee
it comes with chocolate from Belgium
milk chocolate no your copy I'm no
coffee expert but this pairing works
really well normally when we go to
Starbucks it's more like a grab-and-go
kind of experience this is really one of
those coffees that you kind of have to
sit down and enjoy your time and really
like taste the coffee
two down two more to go
[Music]
[Music]
so there's two floors we're on the
second floor now leads to vana section
everything here is about tea which is
our third drink is actually a specialty
tea drink the sparkling silver needle it
looks like this there is a couple of
ingredients including silver needle tea
which is a type of white tea from China
and then there's also strawberry sugar
cubes that you now can't see very much
of but it was really cool when you put
it in and it just started fizzing like
crazy they actually put this in this
sort of nitrile machine giving it some
bubbly effects I don't really know what
to expect the quality of the tea is so
good this taste of it is very light
what's really cool about this drink too
is that it kind of touches upon like
mixology it's almost like making a
cocktail but with teens so they're
experimenting with like a lot of
different flavors this Starbucks is
really stepping up their game this is
really good it's probably my favorite so
far I would say which is awkward because
it's not coffee
[Music]
we are on our last drink a hazelnut
whisperer
it's a very hot milk foam on the very
top a shot of expresso there's also
regular milk flavored with some sort of
chocolate hazelnut syrup a very pretty
sort of three layered drink this is the
first cold coffee drink you can really
smell the hazelnut in here debbye milk
moustache normally at Starbucks when you
have like a syrup based drink you
usually only taste the syrup and you
don't really taste the coffee this is
the other way around so in this case you
really only taste a hint of hazelnut
which I absolutely love also interesting
facts they actually don't serve any
crappity notes here they really want to
keep it true to the coffee drinks you
normally find at cafes we're gonna now
move on to food
[Music]
yura half the pizza that came with the
tasting journey it is a house-made pizza
with Italian sausage asparagus and
mushroom it's apparently made and like
the traditional Italian ovens that they
have in the house this is really good
first start with sweet side you can
taste that especially made ingredients
are super fresh that crust country on
the outside is soft on the inside if you
told me this came from a pizzeria I
would believe it I'm gonna end it off
with a chocolate cake that actually was
recommended to me by people here it's a
dark chocolate cake with mousse and
chocolate curls the texture is very very
smooth and it just melts in your mouth
there's a sort of bitter sweetness to it
this is probably one of those few
chocolate cakes that he would be able to
finish a whole slice of without feeling
like you're gonna be sick
everything here has surpassed my
expectations that people here genuinely
like really passionate about coffee
I am super super impressed if you
haven't been here you should really
check this place out I'm probably not
gonna be able to get any sleep tonight
but you know what it's gonna be worth it
[Music]